previously we've discussed Hades
Poseidon and Demeter which means out of
the original six Olympians were left
with Zeus Hera and Hestia today we'll be
examining the most overlooked of these
Hestia the goddess of the home the
hearth and family that means we can
leave the troubled couple of Zeus and
Hera until last as they are responsible
for the majority of stories and drama
within Greek mythology something that
Hestia tends to stay away from which is
why we don't see her in as many stories
as some of the other deities as one of
the original six Olympians she was the
daughter of Cronus and Rhea there is
some debate as to who the oldest was out
of the three sisters but most poets and
historians seem to agree that Hestia was
the first spawn which also means she was
the first to be swallowed by her father
when the Olympians rose to power both
Poseidon and Apollo were after Hestia's
hand in marriage but she declined both
offers instead she took an oath blessed
by Zeus stating that she would remain an
eternal virgin and take her place upon
the royal hearth there is a Homeric hymn
which mentions this sequence of events
him v is devoted to Aphrodite and names
three virgin goddesses Athena Artemis
and Hestia it is fairly long so I've
just taken the segment's that mentioned
Hestia in particular yet there are three
hearts she cannot bed nor yet ensnare
she being Aphrodite and the three Hearts
referring to the Virgin goddesses and
Aphrodite's inability to make them fall
in love nor yet does the poor maiden
Hestia love Aphrodite's works
she was the firstborn child of Wiley
Cronus and youngest - by the will of
Zeus who holds the aigis a queen he made
him both Poseidon and apollo sought to
wed but she was wholly unwilling nay
stubbornly refused and touching the head
of father Zeus who holds the aigis she
that fair goddess wore great oath which
in truth had been fulfilled that she
would be a maiden all her days so Zeus
the father gave her a high honor instead
of marriage and she has her place in the
midst of the house and has the richest
portion in all the temples of the gods
she has her share of Honor and among all
mortal men she is chief of the goddesses
of these three Aphrodite cannot bend or
ensnare their hearts there's more than a
few things here that need to be
explained it says that she was the
firstborn child of Cronus but also the
youngest what this is referring to is
the notion that the Olympians were born
twice once from their mother Rhea and
then again when they were expelled from
their father
Hestia was the firstborn which means she
was also the first to be swallowed when
Zeus came and gave his father the potion
which caused him to throw up the rest of
the Olympians Hestia was the last which
I guess makes sense if she was at the
very bottom of his stomach the hem goes
on to say that even the most powerful
deity such as Zeus and Hera are led
astray by Aphrodite which in this case
means love and temptation so we do get
some insight into Hestia's character
it's quite selfless to reject love and
then take an oath to remain that way so
you can dedicate your life to performing
your duties she was known as the goddess
of domestic life so all happiness and
blessings within the home were
attributed to Hestia some believe she
and Hermes are responsible for teaching
man how to build houses and as a result
a small part of Hestia dwells in every
household
it's also why Hestia and Hermes often
appear to get
as teachers and protectors of man's work
going back to the hymn there are still a
few things we need to explain and she
has her place in the myths of the house
and has the richest portion in all the
temples of the God she has her share of
honor and among all mortal men she is
chief of the goddesses now again some of
this at first glance may not make sense
we've just discussed how she governed
the home so saying she has the richest
portion of the house that's fine in all
the temples of the gods she has her
share of Honor and among all mortal men
she's the chief of the goddesses that
needs some explaining to most people the
chief goddess would either be Athena
because of how widely worship she was or
Hera as the wife of Zeus but if we
approach this idea from a day-to-day
perspective the majority of worship and
sacrifice would not be done in the
temples of the gods much like many
religious people today only visit their
place of worship once or maybe a few
times a week instead the altar in all
homes where sacrifices would occur to
domestic gods was the hearth Hestia
being the goddess of the hearth and the
sacrificial flame which was found in all
temples was therefore present in the
worship of all deities often being
invoked first she may not have had the
most temples or the biggest cult but
Hestia was a gateway to the worship of
all other gods
she took a share of all the sacrifices
offered and to men and women she was the
chief goddess because without her there
was no worship most towns also had a
public earth in some kind of community
building because they believed just as
Hestia would look after them
domestically a public earth would create
a harmonious town there were very few
temples dedicated to Hestia and those
that were rarely had her image merely
just an altar but when you take into
account that every hearth was
technically a place where she could be
worshipped it's no surprise the ancient
Greeks mostly chose to build temples
honoring the other deities on the rare
occasion we do see a physical depiction
she appears
either a hooded woman wearing a modest
cloak or as a woman holding a staff near
fire interestingly enough it became a
superstition for those who move towns to
take the fire that burned from their
mother town to their new town believing
this would bring good fortune if we do
go back to him five briefly it was Zeus
who granted Hestia her position and
given that it is Zeus you'd assume there
would be some benefit for him behind
everything if you are gonna have someone
maintain the fires of the Olympian
hearth all day then who better than the
goddess of the earth herself if you're
also going to have more affairs than
warm dinners like Zeus you may need all
the domestic blessings you can get when
you get back home to Olympus in order to
maintain and keep the fires of the
Olympian hearth burning Hestia would use
fat from animals that were sacrificed by
mortals to the gods if the supply ran
dry then the fire would no longer burn
and as a result the fires on earth would
also die so there was quite a big
emphasis placed on burning a portion of
your food as an offering when cooking to
keep both fires burning the court of
Hestia much like Demeter was governed by
women as they were the ones in control
of domestic activity in most households
Hestia acted as the woman's guide there
is a Homeric hymn to Hestia but it's one
of the shortest in the hide Wellings of
all both deathless gods and men who walk
on earth you have gained an everlasting
abode and highest honor glorious is your
portion annual Rite for without you
mortals hold no banquet where one does
not Julie pour sweet wine in offering to
Hestia both first and last and you
slayer of argus son of zeus and maya
messenger of the Blessed gods bearer of
the golden rod giver of good be
favourable and help us you and Hestia
the worship fallen dear come and dwell
in this glorious house in friendship
together for you to well knowing the
noble actions of men aid on their wisdom
and their
Hale daughter of Cronus and you also
Hermes bearer of the golden rod now I
will remember you and another song also
this reinforces the notion of how
reliant to mortals were on Hestia
without her there is no food there is no
fire and there is no connection to the
gods the second half of this hymn is
referring to Hermes who alongside Hestia
were man's two greatest teachers and
allies among the gods when it comes to
stories featuring Hestia only a few come
to mind you of course have the story of
Cronus swallowing his children but we've
already discussed that you also have the
time Zeus was the throne and the likes
of Poseidon Apollo and Athena argued
over which of them should rule Hestia
was among the few deities who showed no
interest and while the others put their
names forward she continued tending the
hearth the most eventful story she
appears in involves the god Priapus it
begins at a great feast held by rare all
the gods and goddesses were invited as
well as he nymphs and the satyr except
salinas but he came anyway all who
attended had a great time and consumed
so much wine that the entire party was
intoxicated everyone was stumbling
around and laying on the grass trying to
sober up
Hestia decided she would take a nap
outside Priapus was stalking around the
garden looking for some nymphs to get
frisky with when he came across Hestia
asleep on the grass he approached her
quietly as to not wake her but stumbling
by on his donkey came salinas as Priapus
began to get heavy-handed the donkey led
out of bellowing Brae which woke Hestia
from her sleep she brushed off Priapus
and alerted the other gods who came
swiftly and gave him the beating he
deserved it does make you wonder if the
reaction would have been the same if it
was a random nymph or not one of the
Virgin goddesses especially one valued
as highly as Hestia
the Roman iteration of Hestia was known
as vesta who was also the goddess of the
hearth home and family she did appear in
human form occasionally but she was more
commonly represented by the fire in her
temple the 7th of June until the 15th of
June marked a holiday in her name known
as the vest alia during this period her
female followers would walk her temple
barefoot and present to Vesta offerings
of food
similar to Hestia the Romans valued
Vesta extremely highly and her holiday
was one of the most important to
summarize Hestia is one of those deities
from a storytelling standpoint who
doesn't really appear in Greek mythology
but if you look at the more practical
religious side she played a large part
in the ancient Greeks daily life
whenever I cover Greek mythology and I
do always tend to lean towards the
storytelling element and that's because
that's what I find most interesting but
with some deities that just isn't
possible and honestly it does make a
welcome change from time to time so this
is where I throw it over to you how much
of Hestia did you know prior to this
video do you prefer the more practical
deities with less of the crazy stories
or are you in it mostly for the stories
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained
[Music]